hi in this module i'm going to talk
about bayesian networks and new modeling
paradigm
so we have talked about two types of
variable based models the first was
constraint satisfaction problems where
the objective is to find the maximum
weight assignment given a factor graph
then we talked about markup networks
where we used factor graphs to define a
joint probability distribution over
assignments and we were computing
marginal probabilities
now we're going to talk about bayesian
networks where we still define a
distribution over
a set of random variables using a factor
graph but now the factors are going to
have special meaning
the bayesian networks were developed by
judea pearl in the mid 1980s and really
have evolved into the more general
notion of generative modeling that we
see today in machine
so quickly before diving into vision
networks it's helpful to compare and
contrast with markov networks
so both
are going to define a probability
distribution over assignments to a set
of random variables
but the way that each approaches this is
very different
so if you're defining a markov network
you tend to think in terms of specifying
a set of preferences
and you throw these factors encoding
these preferences into
the markov network so for example last
time we just threw
in the transition factor and observation
vector for the object tracking example
so the bayesian network is going to
require a more coordinated approach
so in a bayesian network the factors are
going to be local conditional
distributions as we'll see later and we
really think about a generative process
by which each of these variables is set
based on other variables in turn
so there are many applications of
bayesian networks um or more generally
generated models
so i'll just go through a couple of them
here so the first one is topic modeling
where the goal is to discover hidden
structure in a large collection of
documents so an example of topic
modeling is latent dirichlet allocation
or lda
and lda posits that each document is
generated by
drawing a mixture of topics and then
generating the words given those topics
another interesting example is this idea
of vision as inverse graphics
so much of computer vision today
is
taking images and processing them in
some way to generate semantic
descriptions such as object categories
or scene descriptions
so vision is inverse graphics takes a
very different approach
where we specify using laws of physics a
graphics engine that can generate an
image given some semantic description
for example a 3d model of an object
and then given this model
computer vision is just
inverse graphics where we're trying to
recover the semantic description
using
the image as input
so this is an example of inference on
this generative model
so while this idea hasn't really been
able to scale the scale past some
limited examples it's i think a very
tantalizing idea nonetheless
so switching gears a little bit let's
talk about communication networks
so
in the communication networks nodes must
send messages
just a sequence of bits to each other
but these bits can get corrupted along
the way due to
physics
so the idea behind error correcting
codes
more in particular these things called
low density parity codes is that the
sender sends a random parity checks on
the data bits
and then the receiver obtains a noisy
version of both the data and the parity
bits the bayesian network defines how
the original bits are related to the
noisy bits and then the receiver can use
bayesian inference to compute and
recover the original bits so this is
actually a very effective idea that's
used in practice
the final example is either
controversial or a little bit grim
which i'll explain later so this this is
a problem of dna matching
so there are two use cases of this
one is in forensics so given dna found
at a crime site
even if the suspect's dna is not in the
database
one can still match this dna against the
family members of a subject and here the
bayesian network is structured along the
family tree
and
specifies the relationship between the
family members dna due to using
mendelian inheritance
so now while this technology has
actually been used to solve a number of
crime cases there's definitely a lot of
tricky ethical concerns about this
expanded dna matching especially when an
individual's decision to release their
own dna can impact the privacy of family
members
the second use case is in disaster
victim identification so after a big
airplane crash or some other disaster
for example malaysia airlines crashed in
ukraine in 2014
a victim's dna is found at the crash
site and is matched against the family
members using the same mechanism as i
just described to help identify victims
and these methods are very scalable
which allows them to
deal with well these unfortunate large
crash sites
so why bayesian networks
well these days it's kind of hard not to
think about problems exclusively through
the lens of standard supervised learning
such as just train a deep neural network
on the pile of data
vision networks really operate in a very
different paradigm which offers several
advantages that i want to underscore
here
so the first
is that it can handle heterogeneously
missing information
so normally when you're doing standard
supervised learning
your data is fairly homogeneous you have
training exam input and output pairs
both at training and test time
but
in cases where you have missing
information or your auxiliary
information asian networks can
gracefully handle this missingness in a
way that's a little bit more challenging
for traditional supervised methods
the second is that bayesian networks
allow you to incorporate prior knowledge
much more easily so when you have it for
example you understand how mendelian
inheritance works on dna or you
understand the laws of physics then
visual networks provides a nice language
for incorporating this information into
your model
and now using this model you can
actually learn from very few samples and
extrapolate beyond the training
distribution whereas in contrast many
kind of model
agnostic
low inductive bias methods such as deep
neural networks require much more data
to be effective
because you're specifying prior
knowledge you can also
interpret
the variables inside the bayesian
networks and this could be useful for
understanding
why
a model is making a certain decision and
you can introspect and ask questions
about any of the intermediate variables
and this is just follows from the laws
of probability
finally
asian networks are an important
precursor to causal models so these are
beyond the scope of this course but they
are extremely important especially these
days they allow you to answer questions
about
interventions for example what would
happen if we give this drug to this
patient
and counter factuals what would have
happened if we have given this drug so
these questions are extremely
tricky and deep
that standard machine learning or any
methods that view the world through just
the lens of predictions are really
inadequate to answer so we're not going
to talk about this in this course but i
highly encourage you to explore this
topic on your own
so finally bayesian networks obviously
aren't the panacea in many situations so
often in these
canonical ai applications such as vision
speech and language
we actually have large data sets and we
mostly care about prediction
and it's extremely hard to incorporate
prior knowledge into
your models in these very complex
domains so in these cases bayesian
networks haven't been um
as successful and have largely but been
supplanted by deep learning approaches
but still having bayesian networks in
your tool kit will allow you to use it
effectively when you discover the right
problem
so in the remaining modules on bayesian
networks i will first introduce azure
networks more formally
and then i'll talk about problems
programming which is a way to define
bayesian networks using probabilistic
programs so this is a really cool
way
to think about modeling
then we'll turn to inference
i'll talk about what inference means um
computing conditional and marginal
probabilities we're actually going to
reduce the problem in beijing networks
to the uh the same problem of a big
probabilistic inference in markov
networks allowing to leverage the stuff
that we talked about
when we talked about
markov networks
then we're going to specialize to hidden
markup models hmms an important special
case of asian networks
we're going to show that the forward
backward algorithm can leverage the
chain structure of an hmm allowing you
to do exact probabilistic inference
efficiently
then we're going to talk about particle
filtering which allows you to do
approximate inference and scale up to
hmms where variables have larger domains
finally we're going to talk about
learning in bayesian networks we're just
going to start with supervised learning
where all the variables are observed and
this actually turns out to be quite easy
you'll be pleasantly surprised
then we're going to show you how to
guard against overfitting using laplace
smoothing and finally we're going to
turn to cases where not all the
variables are observed and we introduce
the em algorithm that will help us learn
in such vision elements
okay so let's jump in